Andrew loku Davila is professor emeritus
of international relations at Boston
University senior editor of the American
Spectator and a senior fellow at the
Claremont Institute educated at Rutgers
Notre Dame in the Claremont Graduate
School Kota Vela served in the US Navy
the US Foreign Service and the US Senate
Select Committee on Intelligence
currently he is a vice chairman of the
US Army War College Board of Visitors
his most recent books include the ruling
class how they corrupted America and
what we can do about it an advice to war
presidents or medial course in
statecraft please join me in welcoming
professor ko Davila as he discusses the
topic does America have a ruling class
does America have a ruling class well
well all you have to do is look at the
reaction to the recent elections and you
will see just how uniform they are
there's very little difference between
President Obama's reaction and that of
David Frum and Peggy Noonan David Gerson
essentially their point is that the
American people never quite understood
the great efforts that the ruling class
had meant had made for them
President Obama said after the election
much what he said before the election me
that the American people are frustrated
they expressed their anger they were
unwilling to listen to reason
perhaps he could have taken that into
greater account perhaps they moved too
fast without explaining as much as they
should have explained but really the
problem was not so much what he had done
what the the government had done the
problem was not the government probably
the American people that's the problem
and today David Gerson pointed out that
the American people those who had really
aroused the rabble the robbing ourselves
had gotten some some of what they
deserved in the defeat of their most
extreme candidates same day Peggy Noonan
said well people like Sarah Palin's
really ought to realize that their earn
their way into government they can't
simply go out and ask for votes how dare
they how dare they presume to to walk
the things that they want they were from
positively rejoiced in the defeat of Tea
Party people again they had no right to
demand the kinds of things that they
were demanding never mind the fact of
course that there's some 65 seats we're
not quite sure yet how many but some 65
seats
changed hands no no no Republicans are
talking about how to use those positions
of power gain especially in the state
houses to gain more power but more
powerful what they're talking about
gleefully about using the controls of
newly gained control state legislature
and governorships
for further gerrymandering of certain
states Republican states so that they
can have more congressmen but what kind
of congressman congressman who would do
what and why they don't talk about that
and gerrymandering gosh
I've heard literally and either have you
heard any criticism of what has become a
universal the accepted practice
gerrymandering but now this is of course
this is this was something that was
considered both immoral and illegal
prior to 1962 when the supreme court had
handed down its Baker versus Carr
decision which established one-man
one-vote is the sole criterion for the
legitimacy of of congressional districts
prior to that time of course
congressional districts have been drawn
according to political subdivisions
counties that sort of thing and there
were there were disparities in numbers
of people represented by by individual
congressmen but these boundaries these
these counties these cities were more or
less natural boundaries which could not
simply be translate be be manipulated
for political advantage by by those in
power all of that went away and no one
is suggesting that this this greater
honesty this greater detachment from the
manipulation of the powerful be be
brought back it is taken for granted
that the powerful will manipulate the
political system for for their own ends
but what are those ends and what does
this has to do have to do with popular
government which is for all what the
American Revolution was about which is
after all what distinguishes the United
States of America or moreover used to
distinguish the United States of America
from the rest of the world why is it why
is it that neither Republicans nor
Democrats seem to have seen to have
learned anything from these elections
other than that the balance of power has
now shift the balance of power between
the parties has now shifted no one seems
to want to even look at the fact that
perhaps the American people themselves
have become more active in their own
affairs now I suggest you that this
mistake being made by the Democrats and
I think above all by the Republicans is
is a fundamental mistake
they are neglecting what I think I may
be wrong is a epical change that took
place in America about two years ago at
the time of the great financial crash to
recapitulate at that time Republicans
and Democrats in high positions pundits
ranging from Wall Street Journal to the
Nation magazine from the left to the
right
said unanimously in almost two sit now
not almost in the same words then unless
certain things were done the the nation
would run the unacceptable systemic risk
of systemic collapse of the entire
economic system everybody would lose his
house and his savings
nobody explained how that would happen
and when you ask the eminent economist
who says such things how would these
things happen they had no answer they
simply repeated the mantra systemic risk
systemic collapse one wonders I don't
really I convinced that they in fact did
not themselves know what they meant but
they did mean to gather to themselves
the power to spend some 1 trillion
dollars at first for one purpose which
did it quickly dropped and spent it for
another purpose making certain promises
we which of course are not been
fulfilled but the non fulfillment of
which does not seem to have dented their
faith in their own omniscience now the
American people noticed and did so
immediately the the Polar's were or
stunning 3 2 1 4 to 1 against this
United position of the ruling class and
of course this is where the term ruling
class came from the realization that you
had this unity at the top between
Republicans and Democrats a unity which
which really did not care anything about
the opinions of the American people
denigrated those opinions as ignorant
and stupid now being a college professor
I've had a great deal of experience with
the occurrence of stupidity
and I fully believe the ignorance is to
putting a demonstrable and I actually
take a certain amount of pleasure in
demonstrating them when I when I come
across them and I would have thought
that people who are so keen on these
stupidity of the American people would
perhaps try to demonstrate it but I've
seen no attempt to demonstrate that
stupidity I've seen no attempt to
demonstrate there are intelligence I've
seen simply an axiomatic repetition of
the mantra we know best you shut up and
obey now how do you get to that how does
a such a class arise with such a
prejudice
so impervious to reality of prejudice
which no one even thinks to try to
defend how do you get there well I
suggest to you that the intellectual
history behind this prejudice is is
interesting and complex and that in that
intellectual history is bolstered by an
intertwined with a political history of
the growth of government these two
attitudes this attitude grew out of on
the one hand certain intellectual trends
on the other hand the growth of
government and they these two trends
became personified in certain people the
intellectual side is quite
straightforward it begins with the
rejection of the notion of human
equality upon which this country was
founded a rejection in the early 19th
century that rejection was based on a
certain belief in a certain conception
rather in some of science saya primarily
biology biology was thought to
demonstrate that changes in breathing or
more pointedly race in plants and
animals as well as in human beings could
evolve or devolve into more or less
perfect specimen of the same species and
indeed into different species
Charles Darwin but was by no means the
the inventor of this idea this is an
idea that he popularized and but which
by the 1830s 1840s had become the common
property of advanced intellectuals
everywhere
along with that went the idea of moral
perfect ability and certainly in whereas
southerners many southerners believed
that they were physically and
intellectually superior to blacks and in
northern I believe that they had evolved
morally to a position of superiority
over over southerners but superiority of
course always in doubt as a superior
with a right to rule the inferior after
the Civil War this this notion coalesced
into commonly accepted social Darwinism
which placed the the anglo-saxon race
above all others in superior grasp of
Christianity a superior grasp of
Technology a superior grasp of civility
and gave the supposedly gave the the
anglo-saxon race the the right to world
it was a very very short step from
social Darwinism to progressivism and
it's its assumption of the right to
purify the country the world to make
rules by which all would abide by them
which would improve all the course the
most memorable of these rules was with
prohibition which was supposed to sober
the country and prove with mores get rid
of crime and do all sorts of things good
things like that being an Italian the
notion of living with our wine
but that's just a racial prejudice on my
part but at any rate it didn't quite
work out that way
and progressives have been nor did for
that matter World War one work out that
way
the American people never quite forgave
the progressives for for that and the
progressives got increasingly bitter
toward the American people for their
increasing lack of respect for theirs
for their presumption of superiority now
I remember when I was in college being
forced to read books like Theodor Adorno
is the authoritarian personality and
Herbert McCluskey's conservatism and
personality which proved scientifically
that non-liberal Americans were fascists
and that we were afflicted with every
imaginable kind of social disease Anna
Mae well the same kinds of social
diseases that barack obama sites as and
for that matter peggy noonan etc cite as
as hallmarks of the Tea Party that ie
the American people now I won't go into
just how unscientific these studies are
they are ridiculously unscientific Larry
that's an undergraduate exposed to them
I did a
class project which which comma using
the same methodology comma prove
conclusively that liberals suffered from
all of those diseases plus body order
since it's it's very easy is very very
easy to do such things ridiculously so
if you pay any attention to them to the
intellectual mechanisms you can have
some fun but fun is not part of what
these folks are about my point is that
long ago people like Barack Obama
stopped thinking about why they are
superior
they simply are now this superiority is
primarily they say an intellectual
superiority but as it turns out these
very people are very very touchy about
their own academic records these are the
very people who dislike dislike
standardized testing who treat their own
SAT scores is national secrets in the
case of Barack Obama you may or may not
know there is not one single thesis of
his that is available in the Columbia
library or anywhere else there is not a
single signed article of his in the Law
Review of which he was in fact the
editor I mean I don't know of any editor
of any Law Review
if you wish you know of one tell me
because I don't know who has not had an
article in his own Law Review he has not
there is nothing there to criticize
their is nothing that I grab onto there
and this is a peculiar a particularly
American phenomenon this presumption
there are places that are ruled by
intellectual slobs France for example
for which I have a deep and abiding love
I'm probably the last republican
Francophile live I confessed I love
France and one of the reasons why I love
it is that it's snob ISM is so overt if
you if you are at the top of the French
hierarchy you have credentials that
anyone can see you pass tests that
others have failed you came in one or
two or three or five or six points ahead
on an objective test that others came in
two or three or four or five points
behind not so in America all we've got
here is the pretense of intellectual a
pretense which cannot be defended the
debate is over they say how dare you
question who are you to question what we
have to say what our government funded
scientists say about global warming who
are you to question what we say about a
whole bunch of things well as I said
this is a peculiarly American phenomenon
and it is a phenomenon of which the
American people have become quite
intolerant
now these elections to get back to
politics these elections manifested
quite a bit of that what do they mean
where's is this taking America answer we
do not know the this is the beginning of
a struggle of the struggle many believe
the cooling the
the Republican Party that this is the
end of the struggle I beg to differ now
just how far is going to go we do not
know we will we'll find out and either
we will be instrumental and finding out
let me give you some examples and some
gauges by which to measure the what is
going to happen in future so the
Republicans have control of the House of
Representatives the House of
Representatives a fountain and financial
legislation money bills originate in the
house you all learn that there is a
phrase the the meaning of which I
learned when I worked in Congress
powerful phrase it goes like this no
funds appropriated herein shall be spent
for that's very very very tough language
in America in American law these were
the words just for example the Boland
amendment was prohibited aid to the
Contras in Nicaragua 1984 and the
flouting of which nearly brought down
the Reagan presidency in 1986 I recall
arguing strenuously
with mcFarland back in 1984 against
agreeing to do a bill that contained
that language not heated that's but
that's beside the point
it's extraordinaire it's an
extraordinarily powerful piece of that
language can be attached to countless
provisions with that language a simple
language which it is fully in the power
of the House of Representatives to enact
you can defund all sorts of activities
people programs you don't have to repeal
Obamacare you simply attach that
language to any number of things
relating to it and it effectively ceases
to exist you can even attach it to to
build having to do with the federal
reserve and prevent it thereby prevent
it from selling you can't prevent it
from printing those those values which
it costs dollars but you can't prevent
them from selling it those I owe use by
putting them into the market and turning
them into dollars you say you can do you
can do a thousand and one things with
those few words which the Republicans
have every capacity to enact they're
there after forcing the President to
veto not hold the entire government
budget but countless pieces of the
budget in other words this is a power
which if in exercise intelligently is
very very very
we will know very quickly whether the
Republicans intend to use that power at
all and if they do not then we will know
just how what little effect these
elections there are a whole bunch of
other things that this majority could do
could again I just eliminate funding for
the NPR or any number of educational the
Education Department or any number of
educational things it will it do any of
them in what is this majority interested
I heard one bold claim that this
majority is going to roll back federal
spending to 2008 levels goodness
gracious that will accomplish an awful
will this majority do anything even
acknowledge that there is a basic
problem with the administrative state
like say a few words about that because
this is something that the tea parties
and hope bunch of American citizens have
awakened to very very fundamental
problem all of us when we were in school
learned
we are subject to laws enacted by
Congress and by our state legislatures
even City Council's and that these these
laws are applied by courts and that for
us to be fined or convicted of offenses
we must be tried before a jury of our
peers well we know perfectly well that
we are not ruled by laws made by
representatives that in the vast
majority of the cases we are ruled by by
rules made by administrative agencies
and enforced by administrative agencies
we never get to see a jury of our peers
etcetera etcetera
what is to be done about that well it is
entirely possible to to force
administrative agencies to to sue I
should say to subject administrative
agencies to the anglo-saxon legal system
ie to legislate a presumption of
innocence for anyone brought up on
charges before any administrative agency
and to stipulate by law that no one
shall be fined or otherwise
inconvenienced by any such agency unless
he is convicted by a jury of his peers
the administers a ministry of state can
be brought to heel in part by such
provisions it can also be brought to
heel in part by the process of election
we have heard that by the way they sit
there seems to be a consensus the
President Obama is going to now that it
cannot legislate all sorts of things is
going to do those very same things
through the through the executive branch
through the administrative agencies and
of course we have absolutely no purchase
upon the EPA or any of the other
agencies and if the pH is to do it makes
regulations about coal burning plants
regulations that will increase the
prices you pay for electricity etcetera
etcetera why what can we do about it
well almost nothing unless of course we
legislate that the members of these
agencies boards has forth be elected we
could by legislation force the anyone
who would be a member of these agencies
boards to come before the voters to
explain his program why it is preferable
to the program of someone else who
wanted to to lead the agency so the
voters might choose among them so there
are a whole bunch of things that could
be done to fulfill the the tremendous
dissatisfaction that the American people
feel toward their government
something the ratio between those
Americans who think that the federal
government might do good and those who
think that it is capable of only doing
harm is some these days is somewhere
around one to five there is the amount
of dissatisfaction is very great the
depth of this fact of dissatisfaction is
very deep and really does come down to
the fact that we have no very very
little and increasingly less control
over this government we could increase
that by some of the things that I have
mentioned it appears to me that the
Republican Party has very little
interest in doing that perhaps the
American people over the next couple of
years can give the Republican Party that
kind of interest again the Republican
Party seems to think right now that the
battle is over that that we are quote
back to normal
because they have a share of power it is
entirely possible for the American
people to remind the Republican Party
that this is not so now I will now take
your questions and elaborate on any of
these matters yes sir
well what did you expect look let me say
one one thing in favor of mr. Bernanke
the US economy is in bad shape the
political branches the president that
Congress have given no hint that they
are going to do anything to improve that
the Federal Reserve finds itself out
there all along and it feels compelled
to do something nobody else is doing
anything which might do some good know
whether inflating our way out of our
problems is a good idea or not it is a
way and it really is about the only way
that that the Federal Reserve has
available to it at this point look at
the opposite course of action on the
part of the Federal Reserve what if it
had in fact raised interest rates
immediately the immediate effect of
course would have been a crash in the
stock market
a further decline in confidence perhaps
should have done nothing but I can't
blame them too much or as much as I
would as I blame the political branches
for keeping taxes and spending too high
because it is that level of Taxation and
expenditure that is choking the economy
as for inflation you tell me or anybody
tell me how these debts which have been
run up are going to be paid except by
cheapening the currency okay I just
don't know of any of anything else is
going to do it I mean it's it it's a
terrible thing to say but I think it's
truth yes thank you very much for coming
you mentioned that the ruling class is
neglecting what the people are saying my
fast question there than a second
my first question second question yeah -
what do they know well the first
question is really very interesting
no I think the answer to that is no they
don't know because take somebody like I
just Obama but even a micro juror on
somebody like that these are people who
have never stepped outside of the way
they confuse themselves with the people
I remember I was on in on the hill here
any number of my colleagues would would
leave the the employee of the Senate and
would go out into the private where they
call the private sector private sector
my foot they would become lobbyists they
would be cut they would go into the that
part of American life that depends on
and the services the government look
take for example a a Michelle Obama just
to give you one example I again I hate
to use him because he is by no means
unique he is not nearly as important as
the environment from which he comes he's
not that important and Michelle if
Michelle Obama were the problem we
wouldn't have any problems but she's not
the problem she's merely one of
countless folks
her position she got some a $300,000 a
year job as a essentially a minority
coordinator whatever the hell that means
of course not but that's beside the
point
and the hospital and the private
hospital she's a private company from
she worked made money from paying her
that that salary now is that private
activity well yes in a certain sense but
no in in the sense in which it is
ordinarily understood these people are
not producing things that other people
would want to pay for unless they were
compelled to pay for them what about all
those folks who are making money
producing and selling all those stupid
spiral bulbs that many of us are
screwing into our sockets are they
engaged in private enterprise well yes
in a certain sense and then they may
certainly believe that they are but no
they're not because there would be no
market for those idiotic things if
Congress had not forced to that market
what about all of those all of that very
good corn that gets turned into very bad
booze into but by these enormous stills
that are rising all over the Midwest is
that private enterprise is well yes and
no but mostly no you see we one of the
problems with
and the ultimate answer to your question
is that we have the government has has
infiltrated the private sector in a way
that that has perverted it it is a lot
if you if your son were to ask you dad
how do i what should I do
in my studies to get rich learn what it
is that or you become a clerk for a
judge and learn what the prejudices of
those judges are then sell that
knowledge in the private sector private
sector will pay dearly for the knowledge
of the prejudices of that judge yes yeah
oh
piece of legislation Tate they are like
they have to sign off legislation or
it's not law so how is that it's more
than that I mean they actually
prescribed courts actually prescribe the
content of laws etc I just got finished
giving a class in constitutional law on
article 3 of the Constitution along with
that my this is a class to a tea party
yeah we read Federalist number 78 in
which Hamilton makes the definitive
argument for lifetime tenure of the
judiciary appointment of the judiciary
that said essentially for the system
that we have now and federal 78 is a
very very good argument Hamilton however
in 78 says you know all the benefits
that I am described are contingent upon
the judiciary branch maintaining its
independence because if the executive
branch is the if the legislature after
I've the judiciary branch were to
somehow become an ally a subject really
of the
the executive all of that will be lost
well your point is that this is what has
actually happened and therefore the
conclusion is that the rest of
Hamilton's beautiful powerful appealing
argument in Federalist number 78 no
longer applies
therefore comma since as Hamilton feared
comma the executive that the legislative
branch has become yet another
legislative branch is kind of super
legislature controlled by the executive
what to do the only reasonable thing and
it is not a good solution but it is and
it's not a solution to which I
personally have come with any alacrity
at all is this objective to election I
mean I you know there's this denature
them as spokesman for law yes it does
but they can denature themselves already
look you now have a five more or less
conservative judges all of them
appointed by Republicans and four
obviously leftist judges all of them
appointed by Democrats there is zero
prospect that this Democratic president
or any Democratic president will appoint
any but leftist Democrats
there isn't much greater chance that
Republican presidents will appoint any
but more or less conservative judges
handicappers have been handicapping the
court for a long time with a great deal
of accuracy why not let the American
people in on the game
what harm would be done other than to do
away with what has become a pleasant
fiction that we are living under law you
read many of the Supreme Court decisions
and they don't read like laws they don't
live read like legal arguments legal
pretexts Hadley arcus who will speak at
the next of these meetings pointed out
that justice Breyers argument against
the
against the majority decision the
recognize that applied the Second
Amendment to the states that that
argument was obviously instance eared
because if Breyer really meant that
argument he'll be applying it to all
sorts of other things which breyer
wouldn't do with his life depended on I
mean there is nothing sincere about
Breyers position or for that matter the
position of many other justices on many
other what they are doing is
manipulating legal terminology to
support policy conclusions now this is
not Universal yet but it's close to that
and I can't think of anything that can
be done about it because this is a
change that has taken place in the
culture of our ruling class and cultural
changes come very slowly they are big
they're huge if I've said anything at
all today which you should take home
with you is that events such as the
election that we've just been through
are tiny there are tiny events in
comparison with the huge intellectual
and physical changes that have taken
place in America it's going to take a
hell of a lot more the changes 60 seats
from D to R 2 for example change the
culture of the judiciary so that it
cares about law it's going to take a
hell of a lot more so that
administrative agencies fall under the
the anglo-saxon system of law rather
than the Napoleonic system by the way
parentheses this is something you can
think away with you if you look at how
administrative law in America is run
what it is
what administrative law in America is
you will see nothing anglo-saxon about
it it is pure in a purely Napoleonic it
is purely continental European now you
know you don't change something like
that just by changing 60 seats from
you